le sport et la fin du très beau parcours
des hockeyers des remparts de Tours des
fait une troisième fois d'affilée hier
soir sur leur patinoire face à Épinal
les tours enjaux
hérite du titre de Vich champion de
France 2 D1 une belle promesse pour la
saison prochaine romain Delville avec
Hélène Chaplin
la joie et spinalienne la peine est tout
rangelle les wild Cats se déplinal
remporte leur troisième match de finale
deux à domicile celui-ci à l'extérieur
et deviennent les champions de France
2023 de Division 1 on ne voulait pas
jouer avec le feu parce qu'on savait que
si on passe à l'aide compliqué derrière
c'est vraiment un des play-offs qui
jouent dans le mental mais après sur
cette finale on a rien volé je pense pas
vraiment mérité cette victoire on a été
performant les trois matchs le scénario
du match n'a laissé que peu de place au
doute Épinal inscrit un but dans les
deux premiers tirs temps et solidant
défense voire regrouper devant la cage
les remparts reviennent à 2-1 alors
qu'il reste à peine deux minutes à jouer
mais c'est trop tard la déception est
grande mais ne doit pas faire oublier le
parcours exceptionnel des hockeyers
touranjo durant les play-offs
[Musique]
les gosses sont vraiment battus ont été
respectueux ça a été malgré le long
victoire une belle finale on avait
beaucoup de blessés mais on a trouvé le
moyen de se battre puis de vraiment
jamais abandonner pour que je suis
vraiment fier de mes hommes la page de
la saison 2023 se tourne pour les
hockeyers tours en jeu une saison
entravée par les nombreuses blessures
mais qui a offert aux supporters de
formidable émotions